вам колеги рекомендуємо діяти як народні
депутати України а не зелено кнопочки є
постанова зареєстрована представниками
фракції слуга народу про відкликання
абсолютно безвідповідальної людини яка
щодня дискредитує збройні сили України
яка принижувала наших загиблих партійців
і ми вимагаємо відразу після цього
голосування поставити в порядок денний
постанову про відкликання пані безуглої
з посади заступни голови комітету
нацбезпеки і оборони тому що безог
безугла - це антонім захисту нацбезпеки
ви знаєте що таке антонім це не Синонім
це антонім і дуже важливо ще зробити
наступне друзі це буде тільки перший
крок відкликати антонім з посади
заступника голови комітету далі її треба
відкликати з самого комітету і ми тут
підтримаємо голову комітета шановного
пана завітневича який представляє
шановну фракцію слуга народа і робить
правильний висновок що антонімам не
місце в безпеці і обороні Вони мають
бути де завгодно А наступний крок буде
що її відкличуть із посади депутата і це
зроблять жителі оволонського району які
не розуміють що зараз відбувається і
насправді зараз був тест що ви не
самостійні тому що коли голова Верховної
Ради і заступ і голова фракції слуга
народу не ставлять рішення проголосовано
паном кальченком а це ж регламентний
комітет це ж комітет який очолює слуга
народа на порядок денний це означає що
ви не незалежні ви представники офісу
президента не ганьбіться не знищуйте
парламентаризм а антонім геть з комітета